european nations love their alliances
the franco-ottoman alliance the
anglo-portuguese alliance the triple
alliance and not to mention the swedish
anyone who isn't denmark alliance and
one alliance which often isn't discussed
probably because of the whole failure
thing was the league of the three
emperors which saw germany
austria-hungary and russia twice attempt
to ally together to maintain the balance
of power in europe this alliance was
obviously extremely powerful and given
its ability to change the face of the
continent why didn't it last why did the
league of the three emperors fail twice
so when it comes to alliances in the
late 19th century germany was fairly
promiscuous and the policy reason behind
this formulated by chancellor otto von
bismarck was fairly simple to hell with
france germany's creation had seen it
rip these lands from france in 1871 and
bismarck knew that one day france would
seek to get them back and that the best
way for him to prevent this was to
create a series of alliances that would
dissuade france from trying at all which
is why bismarck turned to his neighbours
to the east the vast russian empire led
by alexander ii
bismarck also looked to the south at the
austro-hungarian empire which was less
keen on the prussian leadership of
germany having recently lost a war to
them but nobody else liked it so tough
this alliance was agreed in 1873 and
it's important to note that this
alliance wasn't a formal one in the
sense of a declaration of war against
one meant one against all it was one in
which the three agree to not upset the
already existing balance of power to
help each other suppress revolts and to
provide some troops and equipment in
case of war involving a country not part
of the treaty sounds simple except that
a mere five years later the league of
the three emperors was over so why did
this happen well there were two reasons
the first was france after its previous
defeat france swiftly rearmed leading
bismarck to believe war was in sight as
such he publicly threatened a preemptive
invasion of france to stop this and the
russian emperor made it clear that if
this happened he'd invade from the east
the second reason was the balkans
specifically bulgaria in 1878 russia
decisively won a war against the ottoman
empire and as a result dictated its
allies bulgaria's expansion to this this
importantly gave russia access to these
ports in the aeg and made it a player in
the mediterranean everybody who was
already there freaked out and there were
rumblings of war as such germany offered
to mediate and settled on these borders
this upset the russians because they
lost their port and it also upset the
austro-hungarians who felt the russia
was inciting slavic rebellions and the
alliance probably broke up undeterred
bismarck pushed for a second much more
formal alliance which would condemn
france to having no friends in 1879 he
concluded the dual alliance with
austria-hungary in which both formerly
agreed to defend each other russia
wouldn't agree to a formal defensive
alliance and so instead bismarck
compromised the new alliance the league
of the three emperors would see russia
agree to discreetly support either
germany or austria in the event of a war
with an outside power and those two
agreed to support russia in a war
against britain for bismarck this was
enough and it eliminated the possibility
of germany having to fight a two-front
war and this time this alliance managed
to last for six years so what happened
the second time the balkans happened and
again it was bulgaria after the 1878
changes the bulgarian people living here
revolted against the ottoman empire and
they declared that they were joining the
rest of the semi-independent bulgaria
which promptly declared that it was now
independent whilst this was going on
serbia invaded lost but it had the
backing of austria-hungary who came to
their rescue russian leaders were
furious with their ally not consulting
them and so promptly dissolved the
alliance bismarck wanted to try again
but he was too busy being fired by the
new kaiser wilhelm ii as such russia
turned to france and the two signed an
alliance in 1894 which set the stage for
the alliance system leading to world war
one
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
kelly money maker mr wolf sky chappelle
corso wolff jerry lambda in adam stalter
jordan longley rodney martin wyan hockey
spencer lightfoot captain cydog marvin
cassell gustav swan buggily wiggly words
about books podcast robert wetzel
winston k wood aaron the white matthew
shipley alex schwinn maggie patzkowski
corey turner anthony beckett coppertone
the mukwopa spinning three plates
charles the first ben ivinson and
scottish trekkie